n'importe quoi toi et ben 2009 c'est
vraiment téléphone impressionnant pour
le prix c'est l'arrêt minute fait
[Musique]
on est à paris devant le pont alexandre
iii qui est juste là pour aller parler
d'un nouveau smartphone de chez aux
milices et leur et demi note 7
on va en parler sur une péniche la flo
qui est juste là sous lui faire un peu
de tourisme par là bas derrière vous
avez la tour eiffel le spot et 30
milliards pour coup de vent oui maman
vous transporte relais alors bon on va
descendre on va les voir tout ça je déjà
parler de lui rémy note 7 à quelque
temps c'était sur une nation chinoise là
on est sur la version française à la
sauce global
on va voir la différence en a été fait
mais pour l'instant on va les découvrir
[Musique]
c'est la gueule il filme pas aujourd'hui
on est sur une péniche s'appelle le flou
juste à côté du pont alexandre iii alors
shiomi a présenté officiellement son
renmin hauts-de-seine jeudi
officiellement parce qu'il a déjà été
présenté en chine et j'ai pu le tester
il n'y a pas très longtemps on veut en
parler parce que j'ai testé mois avec la
robe chinoise je vais le tester avec
l'as rome française globale en tout cas
on va voir s'il ya du changement alors
s'il ya un peu de bruit vous inquiétez
pas il ya beaucoup de vent aujourd'hui
sur paris encaisse qui est intéressant
avec le lancement de ce serait me nots
est au delà du côté un peu ce paquet est
ce qui est vraiment cool c'est
l'agressivité de la marque le fait
d'aller chercher un smartphone avec des
fiches techniques qui est assez correcte
qui franchement on va se dire beaucoup
de monde
un tarif hyper agressif à moins de 200
euros c'était déjà le cas avec leurs
ennemis notre 5 ça va continuer avec
leurs ennemis note 7
c'est un smartphone qui à mon avis va
vraiment faire parler de lui alors
qu'est ce que je suis on me met en avant
en fait ce qui met en avant ses c'est le
côté spécifications techniques avec un
snapdragon 660 qui est un soc un
processeur milieu de gamme de chez
qualcomm
on a soit 3 soit 4 gigas drame on a une
adreno je vous dis pas de bêtise j'ai
mes fiches mais tout est noté l'a
forcément adreno 512 bon voilà de ce
côté là c'est un smartphone qu'on peut
monter jusqu'à 256 gigaoctets en
stockage non ça c'est assez cool un
écran c'est un délit paix est un écran
lcd de 6,3 pouces standard correct qui
fera l affaire
on n'a pas un truc complètement
révolutionnaire mais c'est assez cool on
est dans les standards actuels
c'est vraiment ce qu'il faut retenir une
grosse batterie 4000 milliampères heures
pour un peu nouveau par rapport à cette
typologie de produits c'est le fait d'
incorporer de l'usb type c et il est
compatible chritschurch 4,2 points comme
don qui va se charger rapidement mais ça
il faut l'acheter en plus le design est
sympa alors il conserve toujours la
prise jack on à la petite encoche goutte
d'eau qui nous rappelle les design qui
sont arrivés fin 2018 mais il reste
toujours très actuel
on a trois couleurs on a le rouge
nébuleuse qui arrivera un peu plus tard
on va voir le benêt que tu n'aies le
noir cosmique
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai mis les
liens bien sûr en bas dans la
description
alors là où
schumi a fait un gros focus c'est au
niveau de l'appareil photo et nous
présente une propose un capteur de 48
mégapixels qu'une taille de pixel de 1,6
micro l'idée si vous voulez c'est que
vous allez faire de bonnes photos avec
du détail et notamment en photos de nuit
bon ça c'est plutôt intéressant deuxième
caméra de 5 mégapixels qui va vraiment
être là pour la profondeur pour le mode
portrait et à l'avant je fus dans des
antisèches j'ai pas tout appris par
coeur c'est une caméra de 13 mégapixels
sassafras aussi la faire alors derrière
il ya de l'intelligence artificielle
notamment pour le traitement des photos
de nuit
bon vous voyez que l'idée c'est de se
refaire un peu sur la vague du capteur
48 mégapixels on n'est pas comme
beaucoup de smartphones qui ont été
équipés notamment comme les honneurs
view 20 avec un capteur c'est le sony 6
mx 5 186 là on est sur un capteur de
samsung
je suis dans mes antisèches où est mon
petit samsung c'est le samsung isocèle
germain ça vous parlera absolument pas
c'est normal on reviendra un peu plus
tard la différence entre ces deux
capteurs je pense que ça peut être assez
intéressant mais d'une manière globale
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que c'est un
smartphone qui me permettra de faire de
bonnes photos qui vous permettra d'avoir
une bonne autonomie
un smartphone qui est suffisamment
puissant pour faire je dirais trois
quarts des usages standard sur un
smartphone vous pourrez peut-être pas
aller le plus loin possible en terme de
jeux vidéo mais c'est pas ce qu'on lui
demande ce qu'on lui demande c'est un
smartphone avec un prix honnête où vous
allez pouvoir faire pas mal de choses et
le mur quand vous en parler c'est de
demander un petit peu aux différentes
personnes qui étaient présentes
influenceurs journalistes qu'ils en
pensent steven demers mobile alors
qu'elle invente est tout simplement
magnifique
il est magnifique c'est vrai oui mais je
pense que de la chair il est âgé pas
cher mais c'est comme la gamme règne en
général dans la cour ce prix là
franchement tu es une fiche technique
milieu de gamme premium ouais avec un
très bon processeur qui va encore la
faim en 2019 ce qu'ils font en ram même
si la version 3 giga puisqu'en deux
gigas peut être parfois limités on a un
capteur de 48 millions de pixels
apparaissent
reste à voir si ça fait l affaire
notamment le mode nuit qu'on nous a
présentés comme magnifique
un juge l'a captée avec le capteur de 5
millions de pixels cas les profondeurs
des mondes equideow
les eaux j'aime bien les cymbales your
way café du geek qui avait dit alors tu
en penses quoi toi bats mon 2009 c'est
vraiment téléphone impressionnant pour
le prix c'est l'arrêt minute c'est que
ça donne vraiment impressionnant pour le
prix tout ce qu'il offre au moins deux
sont les gallois cette taille cette
autonomie cette puissance est vraiment
un téléphone sert on sait tous qu'on
retrouve chez sia remise combattants se
dit remis un téléphone abordable ouais
puissant et vient compliquer pas fait et
au niveau la caméra j'ai beaucoup
apprécié qu'ils annoncent 48 mégapixels
mais pas jusqu'à 48 mais capesize
annonce des pixels de plus grosse taille
ça va faire pas des ça fait c'est pas du
48 mégapixels des grâces du bo 48
mégapixels les meilleurs en faible
luminosité tu sais ça en fait blessé ça
va être joli mais monsieur normal ça va
apporter des détails qui sont tous
agréable à regarder
ok cool croyez 2009 est bien aussi aux
gens pensent qu'ils ont une politique de
prix extrêmement agressif ça c'est
indéniable et ils ont
ils ont voulu les mettre ils ont ils ont
par contre ils ont fait une
comparaison avec les concurrents un peu
facile
clairement ils ont dû 48 mégapixels ils
ont pas mis dans fassin view vin qui est
clairement en fois que je n'avais pas
tellement pris c'est le choix qu'ils ont
fait mais bon je pense à leurs
concurrents sur leur quant au règlement
étant le 46e mégapixels la rencontre a
priori c'est le joueur du gloss un
capteur sony là c'est un capteur samsung
sur le ca après savoir mais après ils
ont
une politique de prix très agressive de
100 euros c'est clair que c'est pas cher
à 229 c'est clair
à voir ce que ça donne de très beaux
produits indéniablement de très beaux
produits ça c'est clair et net
toute petite note une petite goutte on
va voir ce que ça donne un visage mais
très probablement lamballe et emballe
moi est ce qui m'emballe personnellement
pas forcément parce que je suis équipé
avec avec les plus beaux produits
actuels je pense donc
le mail d'un projet pixels 3xl donc je
serai pas client clairement
mais
il vit ils vont probablement vendre des
palettes entières à 110 au mieux au
niveau tarif j'ai jamais eu de souci
soit ça au moins savent et ils savent
faire des téléphones bon et pas cher par
contre au niveau de la gueule
j'accrochais pas trop là je suis pas
faim je suis pas un méga fan de la
marque à la base d'accords mets vraiment
pour une question de design et la foi de
m on est vraiment plus dans le haut de
gamme plus dense que peut faire un
honneur à wye ouais enfin tout cas les
constructeurs chinois beaucoup de choses
positionné haut de gamme avec un tarif
super serré donc j'admets que ça vienne
quoi ça vient du sud est d'avoir du
verre en au dos dans le travail sur les
visages les détails installer des fêtes
façon la différence on la voit sur les
détails ainsi pas sur le reste
oui donc faire un smartphone puissant
tout le monde sait faire ouais grosso
modo moins beau et un peu sexy c'est
quand même plus compliqué là bas là pour
une fois j'ai un chien si robbie qui me
donne envie d'y aller avec ça tout va
très bien dans cette petite doudoune ça
va bon alors tu en penses quoi de se ré
mineur cette eva l'écoutent rapport
qualité prix ont encore fait super forts
ils font mal ah ouais ils sont très très
fort
qu'est ce que tu préfères tu as sorti
smartphones qu'est ce que je préfère
il cote j'ai bien voulu tester
l'appareil photo parce que les 48
mégapixels on en a pas beaucoup
actuellement même sur les hauts de gamme
c'est hyper intéressant ça se
démocratise quand même ouais c'est enfin
s'est démocratisée mais après il va
falloir voir c'est tout les ia les
réseaux de neurones qui met à
l'intérieur pour le traitement voir
comment il est raide c'est vrai que là
il comparaît beaucoup pendant la
conférence avec d'autres produits comme
les huawei et autres c'est vrai que des
fois moi j'aime bien le traitement
algorithmique qui fait des images par
les oies oui je vais voir c'est vrai que
là c'est plus net ils font plus de
travail plus le hdr en fait j'ai je vais
voir lequel je préfère parce que des
fois c'est pas forcément
voilà qui fait le plus réaliste qui le
mieux un ouais c'est cool
bon ça va s'appeler bien sinon hein mais
oui oui carrément il ya encore des
bocaux pour ça que c'est quoi sa moc
regardez là ça manque de présence
féminine dansé dansé dansé events et un
avec a beaucoup de vitesse
malheureusement et du coup ça parle pas
beaucoup de couleurs tu vois ça parle
beaucoup de ce pain dragone le le côté
un peu d'écho du produit elle me fait
pas dire que j'ai pas voulu dire c'est
pas vrai mais c'est vrai que tu vas
parlons de toi même tu me dis alors la
couleur et c'est vrai que tu vas
typiquement posé la question à un homme
il n'a pas de prendre par une couleur
mais surtout pas plus j'ai tendance à
être très massivement ou en général
j'aime y aller
smart noire et là j'avoue que le
dégradent le rouge
il a l'air assez sympa c'est patxi pjak
ouais ça ça me tente bien non il s'en
fait tout de suite et patience patience
je m'appelle en fait
alex l'iframe et une douche avec
beaucoup d'humour youtube youtube alors
tu en as pensé quoi tu aurais mis notre
set eh bien il était agressif a comme
tâche malgré 6 me au t1 id a mordu oui
quand la vache c'est que ça s'est pas
mal passé car tout sur tiens qu'est ce
qu'elle est le truc qui t'a fait le plus
l'effet waouh s'il ya eu en effet whaou
bas le prix c'est vraiment le prix quoi
ouais je bloque complètement sur le prix
ok 199 c'est vraiment hyper agressif
c'est cool et l'eau alors jamais
fabriqué poser la question tu écris tu
fais quoi moi j'avais tanguy je suis
journaliste à tv5monde est aussi sur la
jv tv où c'est le ji des âges tous les
lundis alors je sais que la tong était
au chômage élevé le bras pour ce final a
fait la musique en même temps tu en as
pensé quoi qui aurait mis la tête j'ai
pensé que c'était vraiment un très bon
entraînement pour lui très très bon
rapport qualité prix
ouais j'ai bien aimé petit comparé aux
avec la concurrence qui montrait
clairement quand ils savaient exactement
dans quel état les billets donc voilà
pour cette vidéo alors en plus de ça 2 3
infos et tourne sur me wade dise tout ça
sur un android 9 pas et on a une double
carte sim on aura bluetooth 5.0 on peut
l'utiliser un petit télécommande
infrarouge chez soi ça c'est cool en
termes de tarifs conflit gars 3 giga de
ram et 32 gigas de stockage il ya 199
euros vous a dit que c'est très très
agressif 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage à 229 euros et une fois de plus
si vous botte
vous avez le lien juste en bas alors ils
nous ont présenté en plus on a une
caméra de sécurité
donc ça on en reparlera probablement
dans quelques jours par yves très
intéressant aussi vous filmer en 1080p
vision nocturne enfin pas mal de choses
39 euros incroyable voilà donc la
stratégie de 6 1 me est toujours là des
tarifs toujours hyper agressif pour des
produits très intéressants dites moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
est ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce que
vous trouvez les productions omis
intéressant est ce que serait une minute
7 peut vous bottez vous marquez tout ça
on en parle ensemble et puis regardez
regardez on s'inspirera j'aime bien on
est bien paris
la scène le pompe alexandre iii
les péniches c'est bucolique c'est beau
derrière là bas vous avez là la concorde
la tour eiffel et la balle un peu
souffert un peu de visites touristiques
voilà sur ce je vous laisse vous
embrasse à bientôt ciao
[Musique]